all right let's get ready to leap into
another episode of the minimalist
podcast I got to tell you this is one of
my favorite live events we did it in our
hometown Dayton Ohio and it just feels
so great to come back we've done a lot
of events in Dayton and to have the home
talent and support that we did but I
felt really great about the event it was
at the University of Dayton and the
reason I felt great about it is we got
really great questions we had a very
diverse crowd and we answer some
questions that we don't typically answer
and it just felt really good in fact the
first question from Julia might be my
favorite question that we've ever had
and I just want to say that wow we
really salute you Julia for coming up in
front of what was probably a thousand
people at the University of Dayton and
asking that question you were so brave
and asking it and hopefully we did a
good enough job trying to adequately
support you in the changes you're making
in your life and man I just want to
acknowledge you you did a great job and
you were truly brave getting up there
and with that bravery I know some
amazing things are going to come for you
really soon all right that's enough
monitoring on now I hope you enjoy this
live episode of the minimalists podcast
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it
[Music]
live from the University of Dayton my
name is Joshua fields Milburn I am Ryan
Nicodemus and we are live in Dayton Ohio
[Music]
if someone's listening to this at home
right now this is amazing I remember our
first tour stop in Dayton there were six
people there well actually there were
eight people there if you count me and
Ryan and it was that press coffee house
which is right down the street and it's
certainly one of our favorite coffee
shops in the entire country all of our
books were edited there and I can tell
you something weird about University of
Dayton I I used to just walk around
campus I live not far from here when
before I moved away and I would walk
through South Park to get here and I
would just walk around campus and write
and I write auditorally because I'm
weird but all of our books were sort of
written on this campus which is it's
really great to be back here it's a
beautiful campus and it's certainly one
of my favorite cities in the world so
thank you all for being here tonight
because I know this place seats like 500
and there are a billion people in the
hallway as well we're just standing out
there we appreciate you thank you so
much for standing out there and Ryan
before before we dive into the questions
are you just gonna let Randy out beard
you yeah so it has to be men wait what
am I gonna be right back but give me
five minutes
who's gonna take him out here and shave
his beard all right well we're here to
answer your questions so you can go and
step on the mic let us know what your
name is where you're from and your
question hi I'm Julia
I am from Cincinnati I currently
now I'm just kidding I lived in
Cincinnati for a while it's okay um my
question I'm looking more for words of
encouragement or kind of question for
people who so what I'm going through
right now is that I am trying to move on
to be a single mother in my life I have
an 8 month old son and his father wants
to be in his life and I'm more I'm so
for that we argue constantly yeah as
I've dug deeper in my journey of
minimalism I have come to find that our
values are just totally different good
beyond and it's really hard and I'm
really scared yeah um my well let me ask
you this what and what are you scared of
right now right now I'm scared because
I've been with him for five years it's
been a long time yeah but you don't want
to be with him for five more years or
five more decades we just had a little
baby together yeah my parents have been
together all my life so I kind of have
expectations to give that to him too
yeah yeah so I can tell you that my
partner Rebecca she was so her and I
hope I have both been married before
right and my marriage didn't work
because I eventually found out I had
neglected it for so long and our values
weren't the same my former spouse is an
outstanding person every time I'm in
town which is three or four times a year
we we go have coffee or we have a meal
we talk she has brand-new twins now and
a new family and I'm fully supportive
were like great friends in fact we have
a better relationship now then than we
did when we were married I hope that we
can get to that point sometimes I think
I think you can and not always but it
sounds to me like if that's what you
want and if that's what he wants you
definitely can now here's what I say
there's a cooling-off period and that
period for me may be different for you I
know for me it was at least a year and a
half two years of of intentional
distance so that we could both live our
own lives it didn't mean that that we
were completely out of contact
and for you and mean you can't be you
you have a kid together you know
thankfully we didn't have a kid together
my partner Rebecca she did have a
daughter with her ex-husband and I can
tell you this she probably knew for a
long time that it wasn't right she was
felt something was off their value so I
mean we're in a lie I think their
interests weren't even aligned in fact I
think that's often one of the problems
that keeps marriages together but people
have similar interests with different
values and so they can sort of skate
along for a while
comfortably and comfort is one of the
biggest problems in a relationship we
get really comfortable on and that's
really what you're you're afraid of
right now your fear it sounds to me is
fear of loss and and fear of discomfort
I think we're all it's one of the things
we're all afraid of is pain right and
it's clearly a painful time that your
aunt julia and and what i will say is
the moment that rebecca knew that she no
longer wanted to be in that marriage is
the day she had her daughter now think
about that for a moment you've made the
biggest decision of your life is to have
this kit with someone and it's not that
you don't love the person and there's
the cliche you're not in love with them
or whatever it may be but but it may
just be that that was a season in your
life and I have a friend Rob who always
talks about some things for a reason for
a season and this has been the current
season and it I wasn't all bad as my
guess there are lots of great things
about it and so there was a reason that
it happened and obviously you have a kid
a boy or girl boy named Joshua I would
just pretend that it was after after his
dad wait a minute wait a second you are
not the father
I guess college kids don't get the Maury
Povich reference if you say anyway so
here's the thing that I'll tell you is
your values are different right now yeah
and maybe you didn't know what your
values were before and you need to get
really clear on what they are you may
already have a vague sense of what your
values are I can tell you Beck's My
partner and I we go over our values all
the time and we talk about our
foundational values are what our core
values are what our minor values are and
then all the BS that we pretend our
values but really aren't the things that
we think are add value to our lives and
when you move on you're gonna you're
gonna be moving towards something better
and you need to figure out what that is
because right now you're running away
from something
and that's okay if it's negative or
toxic or whatever I don't know the
circumstances your relationship but but
you don't just want to run away you want
to have something to run toward and I
don't know what that is yeah for you I'm
not saying run into another relationship
that's that would be terrible advice
in fact I I didn't find I didn't find
the person I'm with now and she didn't
find me until we stopped looking and and
instead started living a life that was
congruent with what our values were and
then sort of magically that that person
showed up for me I don't even know if
that's what you want you you and and I
think you know with her she was like I
just wanna get out of this and I want to
be single I want to live my life in
accordance with the way I want to live
it and think if you do that a lot of
great things will come yeah um I will
say I know it's really hard but I want
to say congratulations with what is
happening right now because I think what
happens often and I've totally been
there where I've been in a relationship
and there is the arguing there is the
uncomfortable part of a toxic
relationship and then you think about
leaving and then there's this feeling
that comes along with it those are two
really bad choices to have what I'll say
is that the choice you've made to move
forward
like this is a very important decision
not just for you but but for your son so
congratulations on taking that leap I
know it hurts right now but I promise
you it will get better and you do have
to have a mourning period I mean that
you are having you know a metaphorical
funeral for a relationship that you
really that you hadn't you had an
expectation in your head and now you're
you're letting that go and that's okay
um the encouragement that I will give
you is you are you don't even know it
but you are at the start of creating a
beautiful example for your son and if
you continue to make your short term
ashes align with your long term values
and beliefs like that is that is going
to rub off on your kids you know you
can't tell your kids what to do but you
know your kids are watching you they're
very very keen on what you're doing so
you are starting a new life and it is
difficult
no one likes change change is always
uncomfortable especially this type of
change but you are doing the right thing
and like I said keep keep keep those
short term actions aligning with those
long term values and belief so one thing
I do kind of want to add to is when it
comes to the relationship with your ex
like yeah right now there's going to be
a cooling-off period but you know once
it cools down a little bit and you have
an opportunity to form a different
relationship with him right because now
this is it's like you're the father of
my child and now you're reforming a new
relationship with him go out of your way
to really respect him because that is
going to in turn help ya help - help him
respect you and you know um and again
I've been totally guilty of this and
past relationships where I have such
visceral feelings that I mean I'm just
so hurt that I want to hurt back and
that I don't respect the other person
and then I will say things just to dig
her people hurt people
yeah
yeah exactly and I'll tell you I have I
have switched that around where now if
someone offends me like I go out of my
way to respect them because at the end
of the day like that is the only way to
get someone on my side it is not to fire
back at them with something that's going
to make me feel good in the short term
but but burn a bridge and going out of
my way to show someone that I want to
treat them like an adult that usually
gets me treated like an adult as well
yeah so you're definitely doing the
right thing and I and I think you 100%
have a chance to create at least a an
amicable relationship with you know with
your ex still by showing him respect
thank you I appreciate it still hard
[Applause]
howdy hi what's your name my name is
Riley um I'm from st. Louis that place
you guys haven't visited and way too
long a few years so preface I've
listened to all the podcasts and like
everyone talks about the hair like the
hair and I'm gonna have a Kanye moment
here and say like everyone always says
Josh's hair is perfect but Ryan my man
oh no that's part of the rules you have
to have awesome hair to be a minimalist
you're pulling it off no thanks for the
compliment thank you thank you for
coming
um so my question for you is I've gotten
to a place where I've been a minimalist
for a while now and I have a lot of
growing to do yes of course but I'm at
the point where I'd like to help others
kind of reset so I don't want to be
minimalist number three by any means but
how can I do a better job of like
evangelizing if you will to others so
that they can see because there are some
people where I can look at them and I
can see that the there are obvious
benefits that it would help your lives
improve but I don't want to look up to
someone and say you need to get rid of
your [ __ ] guys right yeah how can I be
better and more
humble about that I guess we I told a
moment ago it's not like I left up and
said look at me Ryan I'm becoming a
minimalist and you have to to if you
want to be my friend and in fact I
didn't really look at him and say hey
you've got all the stuff you need to
become it he actually came to me and he
asked why the hell are you so happy and
and so your question about evangelizing
I wouldn't use that word yeah even like
proselytizing like Ryan and I aren't
proselytizing right now like we don't
hope to convert any of you to minimalism
tonight and you know there's there are
certificates for sale out in the hallway
though official minimalist for 1995 no I
mean I it I think it's a highly
individual journey in my version of
minimalism looks different from yours
looks different from Ryan's it looks
different from someone else's in fact I
think minimalism may not be be the
answer for most people a lot for a lot
of people just as it was simplifying
something and so I think the best way to
Evangelos is to live that to live that
life and to show people the benefits
what are the incentives for them as
opposed to the the what because we all
know what the what everyone in here
knows how to declutter their closet
that's why you never see me and Ryan
write an article why here are 17 quick
tips to declutter your closet like I
think that stuff so vapid and it's
actually part of the problem in many
ways with it because most of us not done
well and if you just declutter you're
gonna just fill the space up again if
you don't know why and the way to know
why is you have to know what the
incentives are for you maybe it's
financial maybe it's more time for
creativity maybe it's more time for your
friends and family and loved ones maybe
you you want to pursue an entirely
different path in life and being
untethered to your previous lifestyle
will allow you to do that and so it's
showcasing the incentives as opposed to
telling people what they need to do with
their own stuff yeah I'd certainly like
don't ever introduce myself as hi I'm
Ryan one of the minimalist or even with
someone I actually like hey Ryan what do
you do I'm a minimalist yeah yeah I mean
that would be well it's just it's a I
think it's like the most like perfect
and imperfect word it's it's imperfect
because it creates a certain Connaught
like you think when I first heard it I
thought stark white walls and then he
shows me Colin who carries you know
everything he owns in his backpack and
I'm like dude what the hell are you
doing like I like having a kitchen table
I can't fit that on an overhead like but
but you know I think for me it's this
whole journey is not about for me it's
it's not about like just Josh and I are
telling our story we're the minimalist
great all of you should be minimalist
until your friends and family to be
minimalists I mean that is not what I
hope to get out of this that's not what
I hope you guys get out of it like what
I hope is that it helps people to a stop
the the chaos that goes on in their mind
I mean we see 5,000 advertisements a day
a day it's more than a million a year
like some of that rubs off on you and
it's very difficult to get it out of
your head I like to think minimalism
kind of helps us filter through the
noise once once you know someone gets
passed and always like for me this
journey has been it's sort of what this
stuff
it started it or then it led to me
becoming debt-free and now like Josh and
I we try to contribute beyond ourselves
in a meaningful way as much as we can
now we still have to keep a roof over
our head and in pay bills so we still
need to have jobs and make money but
money is now the opportunity cost for us
you know Josh and I were talking about
this earlier today I'm like dude we
should just do advertisements sell out
make a cool three million by the end of
this year and then yeah like that would
not then I would just be the king of who
gives a [ __ ] right so you know what what
I hope that what this really does for
people is helps them give inspires them
to to contribute to their community I
mean I was doing a radio interview not
too long ago and the guy asked me he's
like what do you suspect like the whole
where I mean at its precipice there's a
whole world turning the minimalists and
I'm like no the whole world starts to
put other people first
instead of
you know doing something that they don't
that doesn't align with their values and
beliefs so they can get that new you
know iPhone 8 or whatever it may be
so what I'll say is is that if you
really want to help other people you can
go do that without even talking about
minimalism I mean there's the soup great
soup kitchen here in Dayton love working
breath yeah love working with people at
House of bread they're great
Habitat for Humanity organization here
so that that is really like if I was in
your shoes that's what I would go to um
I don't know like in Missoula I helped
out what we just moved to LA so I don't
do this anymore but I will do this in LA
but why not when I was living in
Missoula up until the end I was helping
out the refugees that we had so you know
for me this minimalist thing is not
about like okay buy less and be happy
it's it's one less so you can focus more
on your community and less on just
selfish endeavors thank you thank you
thank you howdy what's your name marina
Maria are you from yes my heart is
pounding I'm super excited
welcome I got divorced last year and I
was looking for congratulations
oh thank you I don't get that a lot this
is a Catholic University don't worry
sean-o bhishan will bleep it out on the
podcast sorry Maria I've derailed you so
yeah that was like a really big part of
my life and it was over and I was
looking for anything Direction
inspiration and I came across her blog
and it totally changed my life and so I
just I really want to thank you for
thank you doing that and being here
ISU's I have a post on my frigerator
where it has the five mottos which is
the relationship growth Health's
contribution and passion and I look at
that every single day and it really is a
drive for what I aspire to be so thank
you yeah it's you have no idea what that
means like that that
feel like it could be just you who who
got something out of this and it would
make it worthwhile good so thank you so
much for sharing it and I just have a
quick question because I've listened to
your podcast like every week and it
seems like you guys never really argue
about anything like you may have
disagreements but like it doesn't come
off that way and so it's funny you say
that that we we are actually argue more
on the podcast than anywhere else no I
like I like the verbage you use though
cuz I'm like because she's like you guys
argue on the podcast I'm like yeah we do
but she said no we have disagreements
yeah and I totally agree with you like
yes we we don't argue we have
disagreements yes yeah and but you know
you've talked I think you've talked
about how you have like you may have
similar values but you also have
differences and so I'm just wondering
when you do have those disagreements
like how do you reconcile those two kind
of you know get to a good point
I mean sometimes it just means that we
agree not to dive into certain topics
politics and religion we both have
different political beliefs we put
forward it for two different people in
the last election so I this is really
look at a much more like stark reaction
in most crowds yeah but by the way there
were more than just two people to vote
for just say oh no this is true I wrote
in Ryan Nicodemus wasted then we didn't
vote two different people
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and we have different religious beliefs
and so we tend not to dive into that
unless it's something that we know that
we can share and discuss and so maybe
it's not even disagree always sometimes
just like discuss what are your views ah
that's interesting here are my views and
I often ask what are your views but yeah
we're different we have different
personalities one of us is late all the
time the other person respects the other
person's time I will say which is which
and and and I'll tell you that sometimes
you just I think I think part of it has
to has has to go to being radically
honest now I I differentiate honesty
from transparency right like I will be
completely honest with all of you here I
won't be fully transparent not going to
give you my social security number right
I'm not gonna put a camera in my bedroom
so you can see what I'm doing like
that's full transparency and none of us
want to go that route but if it serves
the greater good or for when Ryan and I
interact if it serves the good of our
relationship then we have to be brutally
honest we also have to be able to accept
that that candid on is honesty honesty
and so I think more than anything it
starts with that sort of acceptance of
who he is
warts and all and who I am warts and all
and and not just accepting that but
embracing it appreciate appreciate that
person for who they are yeah I think the
other thing too like I was saying
earlier what when I have conversations
with people and if someone disagrees
with me I go out of my way to show them
that I at least respect their point of
view and Josh and I do a really good job
of that with each other we don't hold a
count of like well you know hi he made
me mad and you know he wouldn't agree
with me on this one
like I can't recall anything I just
don't hold a count if something comes up
it's because it's in the moment but I
don't sit there and stew on any
disagreements that
Josh and I have I think that is huge to
to not hold a count but yeah the going
back to the the respect piece of it that
is the only way that you're like I said
earlier it's the only way you're gonna
get someone to agree with you so I think
about when I was raised I was raised
very religious very very religious and I
remember that I would go out and I would
like have Bible studies with other very
religious people and I was thinking to
myself like oh I'm gonna have this Bible
study with them and I'm gonna bring them
to my side and I'm gonna show them why
my spiritual beliefs are real and we
would have a Bible study and we'd start
going back and forth and anytime that
person tried to get me to their side all
it did was it like cemented me in my
religious but it made me feel even
stronger in my religious beliefs so just
looking at that as an example that has
never worked like I've never converted
anyone override you know the whole years
that I was religious and having Bible
studies like I never actually converted
anyone because I was always trying to
pull them over to my side kicking and
screaming and that one people hate
change they hate being changed even
worse so now you know again like if I
have a disagreement or an argument I I
will go out of my way to show the person
that I respect him because I know
ultimately like if I do want them to be
on my side like agreeing with them in
some way and showing them that I respect
their opinion hopefully will help them
do the same thing with me and we can
still have a very amicable relationship
Josh and I disagree on a lot of things a
lot of things but the fact that we go
out of our way to to try and like use
those really is kind of learning lessons
and and yes accepting and getting to the
point where we appreciate each other's
differences and not holding account we
can have some good disagreements and and
not get too out of hand would you like
to see more crazy arguments on the
podcast some more drama
yeah like throwing popcorn em right yeah
that there are times where where I just
have to let go of being right I mean
sometimes you realize you glad that
worked in all seriousness they're like
we get in our minds like when we start
to argue with anyone it's like well I'm
right and clearly this person's wrong
and I realize if I let go of that that
need to be right well here's a pithy
thing for you Sean you can write this
down for the show notes or whatever you
can be right or you can be in love and
I've realized that in my relationships
and I don't just mean like intimate love
but like I love Ryan he's my brother
and and sometimes that need to be right
can hamper a relationship and so letting
go of that need allows us to communicate
better thank you so much all right you a
quick interruption if you want to listen
to our bonus episode this week as well
as all of our past bonus episodes head
on over to the minimalists dot-com and
click donate at the top of our website
each week we publish the minimalists
private podcast exclusively for our
patreon supporters this private podcast
shows up in your normal podcast feed
like Apple podcasts overcast Google Play
or whatever podcast app you use and it
shows up right next to our normal weekly
podcast you know the one you're
listening to right now and being a
patreon supporter also gets you first
access to the best tickets to all of our
live events as well as access to our
monthly private livestream video which
is called ask the minimalists anything
it's worth noting that none of this
money goes to me or to Ryan instead
we're using your contributions to build
a new podcast in film studio in Los
Angeles so that we can create more
meaningful audio and video creations if
you already support this podcast thank
you I know that $2 often doesn't sound
like a lot of money I mean it's less
than a cup of coffee but it is your
support that keeps this podcast 100%
advertisement free because
advertisements suck and if we can just
get 2 percent of our audience to support
this
then we'll have enough funds to produce
some amazing new creations your support
is truly appreciated alright y'all back
to the Regular Show yeah and so before
we we we jump out of here I want to
thank a couple folks one is the man
behind all the minimalism
he's our podcast producer editor it
means pretty much everything the man
behind everything ladies and gentlemen
Sean Hardy yeah we love you Sean we call
him podcast Sean but he really is he's
our tour bus driver he is our tour
manager he's an all-around outstanding
guy and I want to thank the
sustainability Club and Sara thank you
for reaching out to us wherever Andrea
is right now I saw her back there
somewhere thank you University of Dayton
yes and one more thing if you leave here
tonight with just one message we hope
it's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works Thank
You Tommy thank you so much hey Josh and
Ryan this is Daisy from the Philippines
I wanted to answer Andrews question
Andrew the group leader of of your
Denver group who asks you a question
about being a leader on the 106th
episode on limits so I lead groups of 5
to 20 people a few times a month usually
informal sessions and meetups where we
discuss topics where we all have a
common interest in so for church for
conferences and and various things so I
wanted to share how I've learned to do
this effectively over the years I should
add Andrew that you're probably doing a
good job a better job than you think you
are as each leader has a different style
so just take my tips as ideas that you
could try when when you're confused
about what to do so I usually start each
meetup by giving the group a little
overview of what we're going to be
discussing
how we're going to do it and then once
everyone's on the same page I'll start
with a statement on the topic and you
know throw out a question so I'll give a
short opinion on my own on the topic
even if it's just something like it
sounds good to me but I wonder if it's
applicable in blah blah blah and and
then I'll look at one member now say
what do you think and usually that gets
the ball rolling after the person says
something then another one has something
else that they want to say I'll observe
people if they look like they're just
shy but they have something to say I'll
ask them if if they have something to
add to the table and if it gets quiet
then I'll throw out some other questions
so generally I list down different
things questions or opinions that that
I've I've accumulated from from from the
topic or I guess with your meetup from
from the podcast or post that that you
guys would be discussing so after
everything's done there's generally been
some meaningful conversations and I'll
summarize all of that along with
possible ways to apply whatever has been
discussed and all I can say Andrew is
it's all about being laid back and going
with the flow
I find that when you're open and like
ready to have fun and and to share the
members of the group also start to open
up they and that's that's generally what
being a leader of the group is all about
it's not really about knowing more than
all of all the members because generally
they actually know no a lot on their own
but it's more on on nudging them to
share all these things so everybody in
the group gets to you know absorb and
process the topic in a deeper way hi
Asha Ryan this is Lynne recording from
Sydney I just want to share
minimalist life hack with you guys
regarding Facebook I have lived without
facebook on my phone for a while now and
love and login maybe twice a week to
check for any updates one feature that I
really like is that you can push the
subscribe button to the pages that you
would like to prioritize simply click on
the subscribe button on any page or
friend and prioritize how the updates
are shown in your feet and of course
prioritize those you don't want in your
feed this makes you feel so much more
relevant to you and your interests hello
this is opal from Sydney I'm responding
to the individuals asking about
Christmas as there seem to be a lot of
dread and feelings of obligation I
wanted to let people know that you can
actually minimize Christmas it was a
long time coming for myself I gave her
my tree and precious decorations a
couple of years ago and often my pre
motherhood knee had scheduled overseas
trips for an easy excuse to avoid
Christmas but as I started raising a
family it had become less easy to avoid
Christmas in my own soft ways and I felt
more obliged to give my children the so
called joy of Christmas but this year I
finally had the confidence to
communicate with my family and loved
ones that I was not interested in
Christmas and would no longer be
participating in it and that I would
prefer if people respected my wishes and
also not including my children in the
Christmas consumption rituals these
conversations started in April and were
often long and deeply intimate exchanges
about values lifestyle and my own
personal dream of what kind of mother
and woman I wanted to be despite my
great fears and anxiety about
questioning this deeply whole tradition
in my family and society I was
completely supported by everyone and I
now feel rather liberated and much
closer to my family so far it has been
the best December in my life
I feel that by not needing to pretend
with my children age seven and two it
has also brought my enjoyment of
motherhood to a whole new level as I now
feel more in alignment I have my
integrity back because I value honesty
and it really didn't feel good lying to
my children I sincerely respect everyone
who does celebrate Christmas it is just
that for me it has never been in lineman
twith my values and beliefs
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you got a hand
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without your
[Music]
team
[Music]
you